what i really loved about thor love and
thunder is taiko why tt here again tries
to constantly do things that are outside
of the box outside the marvel formula
and i think it mostly works here i think
what's turning off a lot of people about
this film is that it is very much like a
romantic comedy they might be not used
to that type of feel in the marvel
cinematic universe but to me he really
knocks out of the park in that sense but
this also blends really really good
horror there's a lot of visuals here
that are unique to this world and i
think that if you really enjoyed
ragnarok and you like romantic comedies
there is nothing to not like about this
film with natalie portman knocking out
of the park christian about knocking on
the park and of course tessa thompson
and chris hemsworth absolutely kill it
here so it's brought up by really good
performances it's not as good as
ragnarok it's a little more flat in
certain parts but i definitely think
it's the worst trip to the theater i'm
giving this one an 8.7